lining up to test for the coronavirus
anyone who has a fever has to stay
outside a checkpoint outside of Sanaa
it's to protect the metropolis of
millions from an outbreak we transfer
people who are suspected to have corona
virus to the hospital or various hotels
suitable for quarantine officially
there's only one case of kovat 19 in
Yemen in reality there may be many more
that's bad news for this troubled
country five years of war between a
Saudi military coalition and the hootie
rebels have devastated the country's
infrastructure almost 50% of all
hospitals have been destroyed Saudi
Arabia has declared a ceasefire but it's
a fragile one people don't have enough
food water electricity or medicine many
people are suffering hardship and hunger
washing their hands is almost impossible
the Zion hospital in Sanaa is still
operating it is one of two with
intensive care beds for coronavirus
patients there are only six respirators
here there are 12 in total in the whole
capital the clinic is large and located
in a sparsely populated area that's why
it was chosen to fight the disease a
start nothing more the UN has warned
that the delivery of urgently needed aid
is considerably more difficult because
of the sea and air blockade of Saudi
Arabia supplies which the United Nations
are trying to bring into the country
life-saving supplies ICU supplies the
medicines that are needed it's been
difficult to do that because of the
blockade cholera and diphtheria waves
have weakened millions of people in
recent years
this makes becoming seriously ill with
kovat 19 even more likely deficiencies
also in pharmacies masks and
disinfectants are not available or only
at extortionate prices I can't find a
mask wherever I look there are none
first they cost 20 reals now it's a
thousand shortage in need are already a
normal state of affairs in Yemen a
corona virus epidemic could dramatically
worsen the desperate situation of
millions of people I'm now joined by
Lisa Grande the United Nations resident
coordinator in Yemen who is leading the
UN's emergency operation of their miss
grande what are the challenges of
tackling corona virus in Yemen we expect
that corona virus and loss of its chart
it could spread faster more widely and
with deadlier consequences again and
that in almost any other country in the
world right now our biggest concern is
supplies and preparedness we estimate
that if the virus takes off in
transmission cannot be suppressed that
at the height of the crisis we would
need 200 hospital but that's across the
country right now there are only 35,000
we predict that we would need 32,000
specialized medics ICU beds right now in
the whole of the country there are only
500 there are only 200 ventilators for
the entire country 400 more being in but
that's clearly insufficient we don't
have enough testing kits we don't have
enough protective and even if we can get
the supplies we have to get them in if
we bring them in by port its clothes if
we try to bring them in by air the
airports are closed if we try and move
them by Road convoy there's stuff to
checkpoints and then there's a third
problem and that's
already we are facing and the funding
crisis of the humans 41 major programs
31 of them 31 of them are closing or
shutting down this month alone because
we don't have the funding it deals with
the odds were facing are insurmountable
these years of deprivation and
malnutrition during this war if less
left large parts of the population of
course in health and with weakened
immune systems can you tell us more
about the particular dangers that the
corona virus poses to the people in
Yemen eighty percent of the entire
population a game requires some form of
humanitarian assistance or protection in
order to survive the population has one
of the lowest levels of general immunity
in the world and one of the highest
levels of vulnerability half of the
entire population every day what's up
hungry and depends upon the United
Nations for their food seven million
people in this country are malnourished
two million of those are children we
know that if the virus is not a
suppressed if it impacts the population
that the impact is going to be
catastrophic it could be the worst
crisis facing gaming in a hundred years
do you think the ceasefire that is now
in place may actually help for more
emergency aid to reach those most in
need
the people who are crying the loudest
for the ceasefire are the people who
came and in humanitarians
the ceasefire will make all the
difference in the world and we need that
we can bring in supplies and we can get
them to the people who need it it's
going to be tough even with the
ceasefire we're going to have to do
everything we can but we can't do what
needs to be done without the ceasefire
these are under United Nations resident
coordinator in Yemen many facts